make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing out and make
sure you guys hit the like button if you
enjoy the video and yeah let's begin
alright guys we are here with the finale
of dark designs really it's not even the
finale it's the beginning of the Joker
war right I love how this is being done
but here's here's the thing I love what
James Tinian is doing with Batman it's
the best thing coming out of what used
to be deceived I love what he's doing
with Batman uh I was I was a fan of Tom
Kings run I would say that this whole
thing dark designs is an amazing story
right I would say this follows very
closely the Snyder's Batman run if that
gives you any indication but what this
does here is this initially picks up
with Bruce Wayne in his younger years
and Bruce Wayne is more or less just
kind of waiting on a guy like wait just
sitting kind of sitting at a table doing
these little designs of Gotham City it's
kind of funny because he basically says
they were they were never really a
design for the city the dark designs
were always for him right ah
but he ultimately ends up basically you
know tracking this guy down finding him
and then basically following him and
then he basically tells him look like I
followed your clues I know you're in
there like I know who you are
ah you know I need to talk to you and
ultimately you know Bruce Wayne kind of
makes his way in and this guy basically
says or at least Bruce reveals this
guy's name it's Cassander Wyclef Baker
now for those two guys who were
following our story our early spalling
the dark designs this guy was the
nemesis of the designer right the the
guy that the designer basically spent
all this time trying to track down or at
least trying to defeat spent years and
years and years in a room creating a
plan so that by the time this guy Baker
figured out what was going on the plan
was already almost done right in Baker's
days were essentially finished the other
funny thing about this too is that Baker
basically you know indicates he knows
who Bruce Wayne is right he knows
exactly who he is which isn't really the
biggest thing in the world but I just
like from Batman Begins that like Bruce
Wayne would have to he'd have to try to
travel 2,000 miles to find somebody who
didn't know his name but the way that
James Timmy really kind of hits on this
to really show how good of a detective
this guy is is he says like I can tell
from the cut of your jacket which point
of Japan you traveled here from like I
can tell you ah where you learn the art
of the katana right I can tell you where
you were when you learn how to how to
slow your heartbeat I know all these
things about you right the cut of your
hair tells me where you learn how to fly
the cows is on your hand tell me where
you learned to forge metal like I know
all these things about you I know
everything about you just by looking at
you that's how good this detective was
right that's how good Baker was you
could take one glimpse at Bruce Wayne
and then say I know everywhere you've
been within the last you know
for long and when Bruce asked how could
you possibly know Bakker kind of reveals
this secret room where he has like all
these pictures all over the place right
and it's kind of like this this is
everything I know about this place fried
everything I know about you everything I
know about everything I've seen all
kinds of stuff and he says I'm gonna
teach you the most important lesson I'm
not gonna teach you how to be a
detective
I'm going to teach you how to lose and
that's a super important thing here and
on the surface it's easy for free to
kind of be like okay that's weird
writing to kind of write it off no it's
not necessarily important to win it's
important to know how to lose because if
you know how to lose you know how to
understand why you lost you know how to
correct the reason you lost and then you
know how to win because the reality of
this is you don't win 100% of the time
right it's like that line from Ocean's
eleven right like because the house
always takes you right no matter how
long you play if you play long enough
the house wins unless when that perfect
hand comes along you bet big and then
you take the house that's basically what
this is right
it's Batman being taught at a very young
age you're going to lose it's going to
happen right it's inevitable but what
you have to learn is how to recover from
that loss and how to go forward
accordingly and so what we end up doing
is picking up in the immediate aftermath
of the last video that we count right
the last comic where basically Batman
was stabbed through the leg by
Deathstroke now a lot of people kind of
looked at that as though it was some
kind of a joke right like Batman stabbed
to the leg
you know what's the case it's not just a
random leg stabbing right like
Deathstroke hit an artery now
technically if you really want to kill
Batman in 30 seconds he would have
stabbed him in that artery right down
there in the groin right he'll bleed out
like that but it'll take no time at all
but he stabbed him in a location where
it's like one of these things if you
pull it out you're gonna bleed to death
and that's why Lucius Fox was basically
contacted to get in here because of Bob
Deathstroke time right
they bought Deathstroke the time he
needed to basically leave right so
lucious Fox has to get here Batman's not
gonna go anywhere he's not gonna go
running out because any major movement
he makes takes the risk of you know
exacerbating this this stabber this this
injury with this sword so he's gonna
have to just wait until Lucius gets
there
then Lucius is gonna do whatever he has
to do he's not a medic right he's not
Alfred he's not a trained doctor right
so he's gonna do whatever he can and
then there's a time for Batman to
recover however long it takes for him to
recover that buys Deathstroke a breath
of time and when you're talking about a
scenario like this all Deathstroke
really needs is like half an hour to 45
minutes and he's on the other he's on a
plane gone out of Gotham City and who
knows where he's at and this is also
singularly more
because while Batman wouldn't normally
have the resources to turn attract
Deathstroke down if he wanted to
remember all those resources are gone
now right so if you end up having
basically Lucius Fox who kind of just
throws like a compression bandage more
or less onto yonder on the Batman which
does enough to kind of keep the keeper
from bleeding out all over the place you
know it's more or less just kind of like
taking your hand and covering over the
wound and putting pressure on it that's
all it really does it's a stopgap
measure right the response is like Bruce
you have to go to a hospital and get
some kind of surgery done or something
like that because if you don't you're
just gonna bleed out and so what Lucius
does is immediately start dropping all
this information right like that man
tells Lucius like they have my they have
the fortune now right Joker has all my
account numbers all that information
he's got everything about me and the
response of Lucius is yeah I know
lawyers have already seized your house
like you're you're wanted for embezzling
millions of dollars which we know Bruce
Wayne was doing or at least I seem to be
the case that like Bruce was funneling
money he was embezzling money out of the
company into foreign accounts and Wayne
Enterprises itself was doing that
running through foreign banks Bruce
Wayne's wanted for all of that right so
he's wanted by the law his fortunes gone
he has nothing right it's just like
there's really nothing he can do and the
response of Lucius Fox is I would love
to be in your corner the way that Alfred
was I'd love to be the guy he would be
here and help you every step of the way
but if I'm gonna fight this off I have
to operate as the CEO of Wayne
Enterprises I can only keep them at bay
for so long so I can't be in your corner
I have to go take care of this right and
it's one of these things where he says
if I was Alfred sure I'd be able to do
that but because Alfred was a Swiss Army
knife Alfred did everything but I'm not
Alfred Pennyworth I'm Lucius Fox and all
I can do is the best that I can do and
so in turn you have Batman who asked
were Selina Kyle right you think he
would have asked that already because
it's the woman he's gonna marry but he's
like worse than a cop and the response
to Lucius is she was shot she's in a
hospital and then he's just like give
like like I wanted to talk to her right
now
where Lucius is a little hesitant about
that focusing more on the health of that
man that he's getting ready to pass out
you know Batman's like I don't want to
hear any of it I wanted to talk to
Selina Kyle
and this basically leads to Lucius kind
of putting his daughter on the phone who
put Selina on the phone and Selena's
kind of in and out of consciousness
right she's barely making it she's just
slightly unconscious and it's one of
these things were where Batman kind of
hits at where he feels like he fell
short by where you feeling where you
feel like he kind of screwed up it's
what the great thing is 10 Ian's focused
on here and it's one of the elements has
fallen under the radar right there was a
really really good moment when Batman
confronted Deathstroke and they were
kind of
going back and forth in this argument
and death struck was like you were the
one who who like like you stepped it up
first right like you were the one that
made things worse first we were
criminals who were doing things you
stepped it up against us right like you
exacerbated the situation and Batman's
response was yes I know and that's
really kind of how Bruce Wayne was right
that Bruce Wayne was like a kid who's
whose parents were shot in front of him
and he's been crying about it his whole
life and he ended up going through all
these different training sessions
learning all these different things and
when he came back to Gotham City
he didn't meet with an equal force he
met with overwhelming force right he
hammer him it's like was it the Dark
Knight the The Dark Knight film he
hammered and hammered and hammered all
these different guys to the point of
desperation he's the one that made
things worse that instead of responding
to them with an adequate force he
responded with more than what he needed
and that's what made things worse in
Gotham City it was Batman's actions that
pushed people further and further and
it's what made things more and more
extreme not only that he you know
because the life he lived because of the
person that he was he systematically
pushed away everybody that cared about
him right everybody that mattered to him
he pushed every single one of them away
and it led him to where he is right now
this was not the life Selina Kyle was
banking on Selina Kyle join it with
Batman because she was expecting a
better life she was expecting things to
improve but Batman made them worse and
so the result of this is that he
basically says like I'm gonna go and I'm
gonna try to clean this up and I'm gonna
try to make sure everything's sorted out
you know hopefully you can forgive me
and hopefully you'll be here when I get
back but he's like I'll just I'll kind
of be waiting on you and it is anger in
his rampage of course he smashes a
window but Lucius Fox was kind of
shocked to hear that Batman is actually
gonna go out right he's got he's got a
stabbed in his leg where he's just
bleeding out but he's gonna go out there
and continue to fight anyway it's one of
these things where Batman is making a
stupid choice he's making a stupid
decision that he seems to kind of be
overcome with emotion but the reality of
this is when he kind of climbs in and he
says Lucius it's not just vengeance here
it's not me just pissed off because my
money was taken and I'm really really
mad he's like there's a bigger picture
at play here the Joker has all my
resources he has everything that Batman
had he's got all the Batmobiles he's got
all everything in Wayne Manor he's got
all the money he's got all the
technology everything that I use in
order to function as Batman is now in
possession of the Joker so here's what
you're gonna do you're your one you're
gonna call up Leslie Thompkins who most
of you guys know is the one that she's
kind of like the the night nurse from
Marvel
she's the one that basically runs a free
clinic where she tends to the injuries
of various heroes some villains
depending on what the situation is and
then he basically says like what you are
about to see in the city of Gotham is
gonna be an attack from the Joker and
it's gonna be like nothing we've ever
seen before right because this is not
the Joker flooding the city with Joker
toxin like he did during in game it's
nothing like that this is Joker on a
whole new level it's the Joker with
advanced technology and with insanity
who in the hell knows what he's going to
do right and so you kind of switch over
to Deathstroke for a moment and this is
kind of a quick throwaway thing and it's
easy to ignore but it's massively
significant because you've not got
Deathstroke talking to Lady Shiva and
her I guess Cheshire eyes really what
her name is but uh but but you know
she's kind of like nobody here they're
all kind of pissed off that they were
used and Deathstroke's like I don't
really care you know they were getting
paid well for it and when she asked like
what are you doing he just says like 9
million people and she's like what he's
like I'm just taking one last look and
like literally looking at the city of
nine million people which is about to
devolve into absolute chaos and
pandemonium switch over to Batman who
goes to get Catwoman because he knows
Joker is gonna start coming after
everybody when he gets there she's gone
he has no idea where where Catwoman's
gone to she's just vanished now
initially the implication was the
Joker's henchmen showed up and snatched
her up know the Joker's hitmen are there
and they're like it was a smart move
getting rid of Catwoman so they don't
know where Catwoman is and and words
where they kind of make this offhand
remark up you know I got the boss
wouldn't care if we had some some
crossfire some casualties and they asked
him and jokers on the phone and he's
like no I really wouldn't mind I'm in
such a good mood go ahead and take out a
whole floor if you want to right and in
where Batman asked the Joker do you have
Catwoman he says no no she bailed the
second that she was stood stuck right
she saw this coming man I don't know why
you didn't but she saw this coming right
like maybe she knows your real BAE's
back in town who knows but whatever the
reason is she's out of here right like
she basically ended up taking off and
that's when the Joker starts to talk
Batman he's like oh you're bleeding out
you got to go and get yourself stitched
up man because with the warden I'm gonna
bring you I want you at 100% because I
want you to know that when you lost to
me you didn't lose because of some
technicality you didn't lose because you
weren't functioning at full capacity I
want you to know you lost to me when you
were at your best right I have your
money I have your house I have your
company the Joker is like an ex-wife
right like I have your house your car
your company I have the kids I have it
all had the dog hell I even took the
goldfish like it's it's nuts
but the Joker's like I have everything
of yours
man I have everything that belongs team
I'm going to take all these toys that
you've been building in Wayne
Enterprises I'm gonna take all these
things and I'm going to use them right
like for years and years and years
you've been fighting me and I've been
using the resources of an abandoned toy
factory well guess what that's not the
case anymore man
you're totally alone you have none of
your resources you have none of your
money you have nothing at your side
you've got no family
you've got no girlfriend you've got no
Butler you are absolutely and totally
categorically alone it doesn't look very
good for you that's what's so crazy
because of Joker's like I've got designs
for the city man
I've got designs for everything I'm
going to tear this city from the ground
up and I'm going to rebuild it all and
you're gonna be the one that pays for it
all he says so let's get this started he
says boys fire they open City on Batman
just starts frame down Batman jumps out
of a window
you immediately switch to Catwoman right
she wakes up to kind of seemingly out of
the middle of nowhere and we find out
she was rescued by the penguin I bet the
Penguins like madness like this is this
is a pretty wild situation like if
initially you know she kind of says well
you know when he asked about the
designer she says the designers dead
right Joker's been playing us this
entire time and and the Penguins like
okay it's like you're you know I can let
you into the private lounge this private
lounge is called the cool room right
this whole place basically houses and is
actually so cool to see the Mad Hatter
again yeah I haven't seen him in a while
ah but if it houses basically almost all
of Batman's villains right and the
response to the Joker is like this place
is basically a safe house that when
things pop off this is where we go like
when things are bad enough the whole
city's in jeopardy this is where we
basically kind of hang out out until
things get terrible I don't see kite man
which really kind of sucks right I love
to see kite man hell yeah but
nonetheless ah you know when when
countless I was like I need to get out
of here the response of the penguin is
that's not possible this entire place is
in lockdown right it's a Joker attack
which is kind of wild right to hear that
like when the Joker decides to attack
Gotham City this is how all the villains
react right there's no like holding the
Joker off it's like okay guys let's all
go into lockdown let's go underground
you know the penguin says hundreds of
people probably even thousands are going
to die we're sitting this one out right
so like buckle in Catwoman it's going to
be a long bloody summer it's nuts and so
you're not switching back over to Batman
who's just kind of musing to himself
right talking about everything that he
learned from comforted how Alfred always
wanted him to try
for better how alfred looked at bruce
wayne who is kind of governed by this
notion of vengeance and was kind of like
you have to become better and and bruce
wayne finally kind of buys into it and
says yes you know with the entire city
with with me being the only thing that i
have left
yes i asked you for a signal what do i
do and he kind of gets one of the form
of like an electric storm and he says i
will become a better batman right now we
don't know what this means
that's what this is so that's what makes
it so cool we don't know if Bruce is
like yes I'm gonna become a better
Batman I'm gonna be more ruthless I'm
gonna be more cruel I'm gonna be more
I'm gonna be like I was after a Jason
Todd died basically until like Tim Drake
showed up into my life and became a new
Robin or if he's like I'm gonna be a
more honorable Batman right I'm gonna
make up for the failings that I had when
I initially became the guy that I became
is he gonna be a Batman who works
alongside all the other villains to take
out the Joker we have no idea we got
away to the next issue but that being
said guys we're gonna bring this video
to an end if you are new here two
comments explain make sure you guys at
the sub button to become part of the
Robin Court you guys enjoyed this video
make sure you drop a like
now we'll catch you all later peace
[Music]